the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good evening people I place so much
emphasis on Renoir r--'s camera because
I think it's so fundamentally expresses
his sense of experience and if you
become attentive to the really quiet and
subtle ways in which Renoir's camera is
almost always in action is a part of the
story in some sense you can begin to
capture something of his importance in
the history of cinema because no
director or apprentice director who ever
studied looked at Renoir res films came
away from it the same and his influence
is almost impossible to fully measure
there there are there are no cinematic
traditions after Renoir that haven't at
least in some degree even if not
directly then indirectly through other
people who have been influenced by him
then shaped by Renoir example and I
wanted to give you one more instance of
Renoir's camera this from a film I've
mentioned but not showing you it's from
the last of his great French films some
people many people would say it's his
greatest film one of the great
masterpieces in the history of movies
the rules of the game the only reason I
don't show it in our course is that it's
in many ways a more difficult a more
complex film than grand illusion grand
there's a there's a there's a grand
clarity or simplicity of a certain kind
it's not a simplicity of character or of
vision or a theme but a simplicity of
intention that becomes clear at least
after the fact in grand illusion it's a
more accessible film especially for
Americans I think these the the the
rules of the game much more profoundly
is a a meditation on the theme that is
also present in grand illusion as you'll
see this evening the theme of historical
transition but it's a much more complex
and and extended meditation on what was
happening to French society in the in
this in this immense transition that
took place at the beginning of the 20th
century it's
essentially it's a transition as you'll
see dramatized in the film were showing
tonight grand illusion it's a it's a
transition from an aristocratic to a
middle-class culture from from from from
from from an aristocratic dispensation
to a quasi democratic or more democratic
dispensation and and this was a topic of
which which preoccupied many directors
Renoir especially and is a kind of
central topic in both rules of the game
and grand illusion is seen from rules of
the game is maybe his least subtle in
some ways or rather the subtlety is
harder to see if you're just looking at
a clip the subtlety in it is involved in
the characters themselves who have
already in some degree been established
in a kind of individuality which then
further expresses itself in the scene
you're going to see the basic situation
of the rules of the game is I was a
classically powerful one it's it's
essentially a weekend of festivities a
marquis a grand figure for zoomable who
owns of a remarkable chateau invites a
group many invite some friends for a
weekend of games and shooting of hunting
at his great chateau in the country and
the the the film is a kind of series of
tableau or a series of festivities all
of which are tankard or damaged in some
way it's as if we have a sense that each
of the festivities or festivals that are
dramatized in the rules of the game are
diminished versions of something that in
the past had great authority power and
cultural centrality but has but have
become now diminished and even and even
piratical II reduced versions of what
they had been when they were part of a
coherent culture it's almost as if these
festivals and rituals have become have
been Rekha are recognized by the film
although not necessarily by the
characters inside the film as vestiges
of a time that is now
and the most dramatic instance of this
subject of the embodiment of this theme
is the scene you're going to see it's
the hunting scene and III I don't I want
you to sort of at least get a sense of
it not not only because it's an
important film and I'd like to fix it in
your mind maybe give you a taste of it
so you'll go out and look at the film
yourself B's to these two films grand
illusion and and rules of the game are
certainly the pinnacle of Renoir res art
and people who know these films deeply
know something important about film
knows something important about what
works of art are so I want you to see it
for that reason but I also want you to
see it to get one more experience
outside of grand illusion of the way
Renoir's camera behaves and especially
the way it establishes a relationship
between character and and ground between
character and environments and here of
course the cameras job is not only to
tell us something about the relations
among the characters and to show us
their interactions in as economically
powerful away as possible but also to
give us a sense of this of this grand
ritual gone bad okay freeze it one
second this the character who that
little character was giving instructions
you will recognize him his the actor's
name is dolly oh and he's the one who
plays Rosenthal in grand illusion in
this film he plays the Marquis
you see how powerful it is not to have
fake music what just the effect of that
is on the film
I shouldn't say fake me it's a
non-diegetic music music that's not part
of the scene itself there's dolly Oh
freaky
freeze it for a second I wish we had
time to dwell on this and I won't do
this too much because I'll run out of
time for what I need to tell you but
tell me what you see here quickly make
some conclusions about what what about
this great ritual immediately what would
we think if we watching if we're
watching this
what's one conclusion you draw from this
is this is this it is this hunting of
the the activity of brave pioneering
souls who are confronting the dangers of
the wilderness right it's it's an
unbelievably controlled and in many ways
murderous environment isn't it
why have we begun to feel about these
about these creatures that are being
flushed out tremendous sympathy for them
we're hostile to the adults right we're
hostile to the human beings in the scene
we think there's something the matter
with this right and of course it's not
in the olden days and the day in the
presumably in the days when when such
hunts occurred in a more in a more
coherent and less and less forced way
you didn't need beaters to go around in
the woods making noise to scare the few
the few vestiges of rabbits and other
game out into the open so people with
giant guns could kill them right because
the place was teeming with in the 16th
or the 15th century or the 18th century
these fields were teeming with game now
in the 20th century you have to beat the
sticks to get them to come out what a
parody of what an actual hunt would be
go ahead
when this film was made I forgot the
number I have it in my notes but I
couldn't find them there I left them in
my office a certain number of these
animals were actually killed in it and
they shoot in the making of the film
that's for doctor number but it's a
significant number today they made such
a film there are rules that don't allow
okay you get some sense of how powerful
a satirist but also how quiet a satirist
he could be it's not as if the film it's
not as if there's someone there saying
isn't this horrible he's leaving it to
the audience to figure out although it
doesn't take too much to figure it out
does it what what what you can't pick up
from this it makes maybe the scene that
I've shown you may make the seem seem
cooler than it is virtually all the
characters faces that you've seen many
of most of them anyway our major
characters in the film and even by this
time in the film you've gotten to know
some of them quite well so they've been
humanized and individuated and that
makes the brutality to which they are
mostly oblivious of what's happening
even more powerful you don't hate the
characters who are doing this shooting
you know them for the comic and and
damaged and ambitious and idealistic and
and foolish characters they've already
shown themselves to be by the time they
get into this scene it's almost as if
they themselves are also victims of this
ritual they're part of so there's a kind
of subtlety that you can't pick up on
just watching the clip that that is
present for any for any audience member
but I wanted you to see that the this
scene also important again to show you
how powerfully Renoir's camera is able
to create emotional and intellectual
responses in the audience in a way that
is in some sense diametrically opposed
to what we might call expressionist
directors like Hitchcock or Eisenstein
might do by manipulating our our
attitudes by constant by very rapid
editing and by giving us high or low
angle shots that control our emotional
response because of the way we're seeing
things
Renoir strategies can be just as
powerful in terms of emotional and moral
reaction but remorse when Renoir
strategy is quite different present the
evidence in some sense to the to the
audience keep keep it keep the camera at
a level that allows the full action to
be taken in I hope you realize that
there were relatively few cuts in that
scene and in in most of Renoir r--'s
work the number of edits is
small compared to the number of scenes
that are extended the number of them the
the law the the amount of long takes
that we have and there are certain
moments in the in the film where he will
vary this strategy for example and you
might want to watch for this in
tonight's film there's one moment in
tonight's film where an interview
between two of the central characters
the the German prison warden played by
Erich von Stroheim and the the the
French aristocrat named Dubois Jew
played by an actor named de fresney
de frame a and and in this scene between
the German and the Frenchman one of the
things we recognizes because they belong
to the aristocratic class they have a
lot in common what they speak English
for example they because they both know
English even though one's a German and
one's a Frenchman and there is a sense
in the film of a very powerful one
that's established that they have in in
some sense a greater connection to each
other than they have with their own with
other soldiers of in their own armies
and the film is the film meditates on
these distinctions and especially on
this conundrum of social class in rather
a complex way as I'll suggest well in
the very first scene between well Jew
and a Ralph enstein the German and the
Frenchman Renoir uses a fairly standard
procedure much more common to other
directors it's sometimes called a shot
counter shot style so that when you're
it's especially common on American
television but it was coming in the
movies too in which one you see
characters in conversation you'll get
relatively rapid cutting and you'll look
at one face then then the camera will
shift and you'll look back at the other
face there'll be a cut and you'll look
at me right and you you'll constantly
shift back and forth this shot counter
shot style but he Renoir uses this kind
of style rarely because it involves the
eye first of all involves the idea of
cutting it involves the idea of
separation
why use shot counter shot Renoir would
say when I can move my camera like this
and show the two characters together and
move it and move it around in another
way and show the back of one character
said and the way the
if the camera if the cameras part of the
action a fluid part of the action
there's more I can show you more about
character
Renoir would say but in that particular
scene he doesn't do it in this first
interview extended interview it lasts
about two minutes and 45 seconds and it
uses 21 shots 21 separate shots in two
minutes and 45 seconds four and more
that's a tremendous number of edits
right and one way you can tell that this
is a and what why would he do it there
because he it's very unusual for him to
use this shot counter shot style in the
film why would he do it he wants to
emphasize their separation their
isolation from each other their distance
from each other right and and there is a
later scene in the film near the very
end of the film we are again between
Dubois and and another character but
this one between de boeldieu and
marechal the French working man who work
in class figure who's who's on the
French side just before there's an
attempted escape and that scene is
almost as long it's 2 minutes and 20
seconds long but that scene only has
three separate edits in it and you might
compare it farewell scene is a very
obvious one and you'll recognize it when
you see it and and of course the reason
is that he wants to emphasize insofar as
it's possible that they are together
rather he wants to minimize the sense of
isolation in that sequence again I
mention this because I want you to
become as attentive as possible without
destroying your enjoyment of the film to
the cameras way of behaving so one of
the ways to summarize what I'm trying to
say about the way the camera works in
Renoir I want to remind you that even in
his darkest films the his camera work
carries an undercurrent of excitement
even sometimes a kind of joy at the
sheer particular nasarah T of the world
you can could sense his his awareness of
ambiguity ambiguity and his wonder at
the texture of the visible world all
through his films of the French of his
the so-called French period and
especially in the film you're going to
see tonight which is in many ways in
environments that are very
poetic right there the entire film takes
place in a series of prison camps the
entire film is about these French
prisoners of war there's an introduction
or prologue before they're captured and
then after they're captured we see them
in a series of prison camps and and it's
a quite an amazing experience in some
ways to watch Renoir's camera discover
the complexity of even the of a world
that seems in on the surface to be so
unpromising and so uninteresting so
lacking in texture we we can think of we
can think of Renoir's camera as shy
timid in a sense capable of
embarrassment even there's one moment in
the rules of the game which partly
involves a kind of it has a farce
dimension so that there were when they
when all the guests in the in the great
estate in the great estate or castle go
to sleep at night they there there's a
they sort of come out of their rooms and
start you know changing bed partners and
things like that they they have various
liaison and there's a moment when the
camera is in the hole this long hallway
and one of the lovers comes out to meet
another lover and the cat it looks as if
the camera actually backs away in
embarrassment and looks away as if it
says oh that let's see inappropriate for
me to be looking at so there's the
camera is humanized in a very subtle
quiet way all the way through
Renoir r--'s work so we can think of
this camera as shy as embarrassed
reluctant to overhear or to intrude
there are even moments when it is
distracted or drawn to an apparently
irrelevant element times when the camera
hesitates or even that appears to change
its mind an uncertain camera then always
adjusting to a world that is itself
always shifting and changing and of
course that's the deepest argument for
why this the camera is so Restless I
mean I remember it's not obtrusive it's
not like you feel the camera swinging
wildly not at all you have to pay
attention sometimes you won't even be
aware of the fact of how quietly and
certainly the camera but it's as if the
camera is always making adjustments as
if it's always alive to the changing
character of what it's looking at and
that very aliveness
reminds you of how complex reality is
because reality itself is always
shifting and changing this describes I
think something of what is meant by
Renoir is realism but there's a kind of
lyric element as I've mentioned a kind
of even a kind of tranquility or
pleasure or joy celebratory impulse in
his camera's gaze that qualifies or
sweetens his realism of space and
character and we need to be aware of
that too one way to crystallize this is
to suggest that once we become attuned
to the cameras forms of attention that's
a good phrase the cameras forms of
attention there's a wonderful book about
poetry called forms of attention right
and lyric poetry is where constitutes a
special kind of attention we can say
that that Renoir is camera is engaged
constantly in these forms of attention
once we become aware of that of that of
the cameras interest in that we become
aware of a quiet continuous struggle a
loving contest almost between the
multiple points of interest in the scene
and the cameras reluctant gently
hesitant choices the menu of things to
see and hear
Renoir Ray's films keep telling us is
too rich to be fully captured even by
the most generous eye and that's what I
mean when I say that visual style can be
understood as a form of moral style
right I want to say a few more words
about grand illusion itself to help
frame your experience of it it's not a
complex film but it's a deep and
beautiful one and I think you'll all
find it very memorable first a word
about the actors well maybe I should say
one other word about about Renoir
himself because it bears on his actors
as I implied or I think suggested this
afternoon one of the most distinctive
features of Renoir is practice and
followed if you think about the way his
camera behaves you can see how logically
connected these elements are what was
that he was an improvisational director
he collaborated with his actors with his
performers he didn't come in with an
absolutely fixed grip
no disease they in any way he's like the
anti Hitchcock Hitchcock has solved all
his problems before he's come in to do
his shooting Renoir has just begun the
process of making his movie when he he
has an idea of his subject matter he
knows what he's doing knows he I don't
mean that he's working completely blind
but he allows discovery to take place in
the course of the making of the movies
of his movies and he's very deeply
involved in collaborating with his
performers so that for example when he
had already begun working on the movie
uh I don't think they hadn't begun she I
don't think they've begun shooting it
yet but they were very far along in
creating the movie inin casting the
movie when they discovered that Erich
von Stroheim who was already by then by
the time this film was made a very
well-known actor and director much in
fact incredibly admired director both
about both an actor and a director uh
what agreed to join the film and when he
agreed to join the film he and Renoir
began to collaborate on expanding the
role that von Stroheim plays and you'll
understand what and what an immensely
helpful contribution to the what could
we call it to the ecology of the movie
to the sense of the movie
von Stroheim a because his because he's
one of the dominant characters his his
if we if we if we try to imagine grand
illusion with a much reduced role for
the von Stroheim character it's a much
lesser film you can so you can recognize
what in it and what an extraordinary
contribution from Stroheim aid now he'd
not only made contributions to questions
about the dialogue what the character
would say expanded the role but even
made suggestions about how the character
would look what what what cut well how
the character would be costumed and I
think it was a von Stroheim who
emphasized even more fully than Renoir
had originally intended that the von
Stroheim character is a war casualty
that he has a ramrod up his back that he
could yes to wear gloves because his
hands are horribly burned he's a [ __ ]
and that's why he's now running prison
camps because he's not useful for
anything else right and there's the
sense that he's a damaged wounded figure
even from the very beginning of the film
when we when we first meet him
so that's important in itself but
there's a second thing about from
Stroheim that I want to emphasize to you
so it shows you how subtly Renoir was
aware of how he could utilize all the
elements available to him as a filmmaker
von Stroheim was especially well known
as an actor for roles in which he would
play this was especially true in roles
he played in the United States in which
you would play a dangerous scary
martinet a kind of a kind of there were
even hints of sadomasochism about the
role sometimes so he would play he would
play a brutal brutal prison camp above
wardens right a brutal police types
brutal brutal military types right
violent husbands right he became and in
fact he was understood also as a villain
he often played roles that were
recognizably evil roles he came to be
known as the man you love to hate that
was like his sort of it was a sort of
model that was attached to his to his
name and when you watch grand illusion
one of the things I hope you'll think
about is the complete look the complex
way in which that inherited idea of the
von stroheim character is complicated
undermined and humanized because in many
ways he still is the villain in the
piece but he's a humanized villain he's
a kind he becomes a complex character as
much a victim of what's happening of
history as much a victim of history as
any of the other characters in the film
so there's a sense in which this in
which what what Renoir and von stroheim
together are doing is taking the persona
that von Stroheim had established and
undercutting it undermining it in some
in some slight way creating a much
greater resonance for the character
exactly because of the ways in which he
first that appears to fulfill the
expectations that he's an evil villain
and then as the film goes on the sense
is undermined complicated and you
realize that he's a he's a human being
with with powers of generosity although
also certain limitations he's prejudiced
he is a German he's prejudiced he has he
doesn't really like the French
especially doesn't like working-class
people most especially doesn't like Jews
right I mean it's not he's an imperfect
character but you see that he's deeply
who
and something of the same kind of thing
happens in the film's treatment of the
Jean Gabin character they really he's
the character plays Mary shall hit the
actor who plays marichal the
working-class Frenchmen who along with
Dubois Jew and and the the Jew played by
that the Jew played by Dalio a character
called Rosenthal these three are the
central French characters and we see
them moving from prison camp to prison
camp through the film if that group is
the central group of the film and we
follow them as the film goes on the
Gabin character too was in many ways the
most famous actor of if not in Europe
certainly in France of the late 20s and
30s I'm a major major figure and he was
especially associated with working-class
roles and most especially associated
with roles he was like an early Jack
Nicholson an even more powerful version
of it because he became famous for these
moments in the films when he would go
nuts when he would have a fit when he
would start screaming or he would lose
it he would he would rant or a rave or
and and and in some of the films in some
films he was in he would have a
climactic scene this may be in fact
where the stereotype began he would have
a climactic scene often he was a like he
would be a suicidal proletarian right
now a suicidal worker
up against the forces of capitalism or
the forces of the police right the Gabin
character had frequent roles like this
in which he would in which he would
essentially lose lose all rational
control and rant and rave and scream
sometimes die right and he he was so
famous for this and this was such a
fundamental part of his persona that he
had written into most of his contracts
that he had to have a scene in which he
did this he had to have at least one
scene in the film in which he sort of
went Cucamonga in which he in which he
lost that right now one of the most
subtle things about this film is there
is a such a moment in this film watch
what you mean because it's so quiet
compared to what you might expect that
you might miss it but it's really there
and in fact the way in which it both
fulfills but also undermines our
expectations
about this character again tells us
something about the way in which Renoir
and his collaborating actors were able
to create immensely nuanced meanings of
possibilities out of the raw material of
their of not only of the story of the
filming of the setting of the film but
even the past history of the performers
I want to say just a couple of things
about some of the dominant themes in the
film to help organize your experience of
it and I'm borrowing here or deeply
influenced here by two critics
especially although I mean I perhaps I
should say parenthetically you should
probably assume that almost anything I
say has been said by someone else
somewhere some as at some time in the
past and it was the job of a teacher as
I conceive it is not to come up with
totally original arguments every time
because no one can be so original as to
say everything that's wonderful about
particular text or about a whole
phenomenon like the movies right so a
good teacher draws on that and I'm
alright when I really am drawing on a on
a prior scholar who I know has shaped
the arguments I'm making or has given me
the the categories I'm using I mention
them by name but of course I've been
teaching for so long that much of this
must not be and unconsciously absorbed
into my into my psyche and I don't
always know this so I'm not saying that
those moments where I haven't made this
acknowledgement are free of such
influence quite the opposite but I do
want to mention two scholars who have
especially influenced me on on Renoir
because virtually all the things I've
told you about Renoir I've made the
ideas my own come from these one is a
frenchman named alexander soshalskiy and
i wrote a wonderful book on i think its
several volume book on Renoir that
taught me a tremendous amount especially
about his French period and the other is
the is the California scholar now
California scholar Leo Brody
one of whose essays I've asked you to
read in this course and he's written a
wonderful book on Renoir and although I
have read the book I learned more about
Renoir from Brodie in conversation
because he was my colleague
many years ago when we were teaching
together in the English department at
Yale and he's one of the people who
turned me into a person interested in
movies interested in film so Leo Brody
be our AUD why alexander soshalskiy
SES ons ke the two principal scholars
and critics behind what I've been saying
both this afternoon and this evening
dominant themes one the prison camp as a
microcosm right there's a wonderful
passage at one point in the in the movie
where one of the characters said
everyone would die of the disease of his
class if the war did not reconcile all
microbes and think about the
implications of that because the idea is
that what the one of the things that
makes this prison camp such a
fascinating place is that it is in some
sense a microcosm of the larger world
and and in especially if you if you
think of the prison camp beyond just the
the grouping of the French soldiers whom
the French prisoners when we follow
primarily what you can recognize is for
you back away because we are told about
a we meet and we see briefly some of the
other prisoners they were there are
Russian prisoners and other kinds of
prisoners as well there's other kinds of
prisoners as well there's a there's a
sense that that that the prison camp is
a kind of microcosm or at least of
Europe if not of if not of the world as
a whole and more specifically the way in
which the prison camp is a microcosm for
the social striations that organize
outer society there's a working class
there's a there's it seems to be a
middle class there you'll notice that
there's a scholar who born right who has
a copy of Pindar the the the great
ancient poet who think and who treasures
his work on pin he's one of my favorite
minor characters in the film because of
his commitment to literature despite the
war and despite the miseries of prison
camp right and what you what you can see
is in a certain sense is that Renoir is
delighted by the idea that that a that a
kind of microcosm is created and if you
watch the variations amongst the
Frenchmen and again if you think about
that fragment of a scene eyes
this afternoon of these characters at
dinner table in the in in the in the
prison camp you'll begin to see more
fully how powerfully and interestingly
complexly he differentiates his
characters from each other that fragment
that you saw I hope you realized one of
the characters was an actor and you
could tell that clear you it becomes
clearer if you watch the whole scene but
he's a he's a very histrionic and
theatrical character he bursts into song
all the time right
and then there's the aristocrat who's
looking down his monocle very very
austerely and then it seems that his lip
seams in curled in a permanent gesture
of condescension and so forth watch how
how richly how complexly the characters
are distinguished from each other by
social class by profession but and so
and so forth I don't want to romanticize
or idealize what I'm saying this
argument because I'm not suggesting that
when he says it's a microcosm of the
world he wants to celebrate that
microcosm although he he's interested in
it Renoir is also aware of the
limitations that it's not as if he's
suggesting that this is a perfect
community at all one reason is they're
forced together but they're being forced
together makes them share it forces them
to come out of their limitations in
certain way to overcome certain of their
prejudices although never fully right
but what it also does is reveal them and
we can and we can see how both processes
the the the process of sort of adjusting
to people different from yourself and
maybe overcoming some of your class or
racial prejudices or is a part of the
experience that the characters in the
film have but another part of the
experience is that they come up against
the differences between them some of
which can never be breached let me
mention one scene which dramatizes this
am big ambiguity very deeply there's one
moment in the film very powerful moments
I think in which one care in which the
merit the the character played by GABA
the Marechal character is wounded in a
good part of the early part of the film
and the in fact in the dinner scene that
I showed you this afternoon you will see
that at a certain point his comrades
sitting at the table cuts his meat for
him because his hand is in
and I don't know if it's in this scene
or a subsequent scene there's a moment
when another character in the film
washes mera shells feet why is foot
washing instantly a symbolic thing
who knows the answer alright there's a
scene in the Bible in in in the twelfth
chapter of John in which in which in
which Mary or Martha I can't remember
which washes Christ's feet and then in
the very next chapter and in the very
next chapter it said that the Last
Supper
Christ Himself washes the feet of his
disciples and in fact the washing of
feet is is in Catholic and in certain
other Christian rituals an actual
official ritual it used to be much more
common than it is today but it's still
done in certainly Catholic countries at
the advent of the holy of holy week so
it's a deeply symbolic act in which in
which Christ Himself is washing the feet
of his disciples and and he and the
message he gives us everyone there you
should now do this to your to your
fellows the implication being no one is
better than anyone else the implication
a radical a radically Democratic vision
in some sense of of God's love and where
has this practice been recently very
dramatically and publicly revived who's
been doing it the Pope the new pope
haven't you read about this the new pope
has been doing this he's a washing the
feet of parishioners it was a symbolic
gesture in which in which God's emissary
on earth is behaving with the humility
that Jesus Christ Himself so wait so the
foot washing scene in in in our film has
this sort of resonance to it even though
there's no there's no openly religious
reference but but it has a similar kind
of significance and and they're carrying
on a kind of conversation as they as the
feet are being washed and what you feel
is boy what a moving scene
nobody is impacted the man who's doing
the washing doesn't feel that he is
being condescended to or that he's being
diminished in any way by doing it the
man whose feet are being washed is not
embarrassed to have it happen what a
scene of solidarity and community and
you could turn this you could become
very
you could you could wax very poetic
about what a scene of community and yet
watch how the scene ends there's a
moment at which after they as he's
drying his feet the the foot washer the
marichal asked the foot washer what do
you do for a living and at some point
during their conversation he says oh I I
he says I am iiiii I am a cadastre
what that means is something like City
Planning he's a city planner and the
sort of marichal character hears this
and they go on there at the very end of
the scene Marichal turns to his foot
washer and he says what does that mean
cad asked the implication being he that
their vocabularies aren't even the same
that is what it what it dramatizes is
the distance between them he's been
sitting there having this conversation
with him but he didn't even say gee I
have no idea what that word means
I certainly have no idea what you do for
a living it's a way of reminding us yes
they've come together yes they're
sharing space yes there's they're doing
something very that dramatizes human
solidarity and yet also how separated
they are again and again in the film we
have this sort of double experience in
which we see characters make contact
with each other or even sacrifice for
each other and at the same time we're
aware of their differences watch for
this it's very powerful and moving in
there was it's a form of moral realism
in which the film refuses to simplify
what it wants to say about human
experience a very powerful example of
this in the relationship between the Jew
Rosenthal who's proud of his wealth is
the heir of a department store fortune
right but because he's a Jew he and and
because his nouveau riche he can never
be part of the aristocracy at his
relation to the Marechal character is
very complex Marichal as I mentioned
this afternoon retains a kind of
working-class can French working-class
characteristic anti-semitism and and
there are moments when you can feel the
hostility between them when the two of
them finally try to make an escape from
the prison and they actually are away
from one of the prisons for a while and
you see the lien the Rosenthal character
hurts his foot and there's a moment in
which it looks like gee if if the
Marechal character stays with him he's
putting himself in danger as well and
they get into a fight and one of them
said I'd wanted mapped the
Rosenthal says go away leave me alone
leave and marichal says alright I will
and it's a very wonderful scene because
they start singing at each other and
it's a form of singing hostility so
there's a comic dimension to it too it's
really rich but what is also being
dramatized there are the limitations of
the characters are mara shells
anti-semitism Rises come comes to the
surface their hostility toward each
other comes to the surface at that
moment although of course they also
overcome it and there are many other
such moments in the film the
relationship between Dubois Jew and his
German counterpart the aristocrat the
aristocratic German is also a version of
this of this kind of thing so asset as
I've already implied a second central
theme of the film has to do with what we
might call barriers and boundaries
there's the barrier of social class
which I've mentioned already there's the
barrier of language and culture right
the Germans and the French are at war
right the Russians don't speak the same
language as the Germans the English
don't speak the same language as the
French and again and again the what
separates people is dramatized for us
although there's also a longing in the
film to transcend these boundaries they
always be can't always be transcendent
sometimes these boundaries are shown to
be foolish and trivial or or Mustafa
right and we could think of many there
are many examples in the film both of
language and of geography as well as of
social class but let me mention just
well two of them there's one wonderful
moment in the film the French prisoners
have been digging a tunnel an escape
tunnel and they've almost completed the
tunnel when the Germans come and say all
right we're moving you out of your
barracks and we're putting these English
prisoners in very deep bed and so the
French are very unhappy about this
because they've almost completed their
tunnel so at great danger to himself the
Marechal character breaks ranks dropped
and try he does it kind of trick where
he drops his suitcase I think or someone
and he bends over to try to pick it up
to give him an excuse to talk to the
English prisoners who are gonna change
places with them he wants to tell the
English prisoners there's a tunnel you
can escape right but it turns out he's
not able to give him the message because
the English don't
Stan French can't speak English so the
English prisoners end up going into the
but without ever knowing that there's a
tunnel waiting for them that that's
almost ready ready to be completed an
example of the barrier that language the
way language separates people and in
many way in many ways can be said to be
frustrating on one more example at the
very end of the film there's a moment
when the two the two characters Marichal
and Rosenthal are making their escape
across a great field a great white field
of snow and they're running across the
field and the camera backs up and we see
them being watched by German soldiers
one of the soldiers picks up his rifle
he says they're making an escape and he
starts to aim at him then all of a
sudden he stops I think I can't remember
the exam in hold-off why doesn't he
shoot and then we see Marechal and
Rosenthal could disappear across the
course an invisible boundary and then
and the German says well they've crossed
the border they're no longer in Germany
I can't shoot them they're in there now
in Belgium but the fact is there's no
boundary there it's all snow it's a
snowy field right how arbitrary that
boundary is well again and again in the
film we have this theme of barriers and
boundaries what separates us and also
one last thing about the question of
social class maybe the most disturbing
and powerful insight that the film has
about social class one that Americans
tend to resist but I encourage you not
to resist it those of you not from the
United States will perhaps understand
this more easily although Americans need
to understand it is the extent to which
one social class shapes one's identity
that is to say one of the things we feel
in this film is that did well Jews
nature is a function of his having been
raised as an aristocrat there are
wonderful scenes between Guangzhou and
Malaysia where Michelle says to him this
a wall between us and you you're so
under monstre t'v and Marichal doesn't
trust him because he's because he
belongs to me he belongs to a different
class even though of course they're
Frenchmen after all and in the end
nationality Trump's class in this in
this film as you'll see as you'll see
but in this kind in this in this sort of
distinction or difference between
Michelle and Doug well Joe we have
another
expression of this of the sense of the
of this idea or this recognition that
one's personality itself what one likes
and dislikes ones fundamental nature is
the impart shaped by the classing to
which one is born we're not born utterly
free
we don't have absolute choice in what we
are or what we become our characters are
shaped controlled by the circumstances
in which we live and the film profoundly
understands that it understands our
desire to reach those limitations to go
beyond them and it celebrates our
impulse to do so but it also recognizes
the degree to which we remain confined
within personalities that are partly
controlled or shaped by forces far
beyond our individual control and that
are especially located in the social
class to which we belong finally as I
mentioned this afternoon the theme of
historical transition is at the heart of
this remarkable film and you'll
understand very clearly what is going on
there again dramatized even more
complexly and fully in rules of the game
it's a central topic here the an
aristocratic traditions are giving way
to modernity in this film and we're
aware of them in all kinds of ways even
in the nostalgic way in which to dwell
Jew and Ralph and Stein carry on their
conversations they talk about they know
things they have they have experiences
in common because they belong to the
aristocracy a class that transcended in
some sense or at least in part
transcended national origins that
aristocratic dispensation is
disappearing in fact the first world war
completely obliterated it and Renoir is
not the only one to have said that there
a number of wonderful
apart from scholarship there a number of
wonderful novels for example that deal
with this with with the transformation
of European society because of the
because of the First World War and
Renoir is film is is is one such is one
such text Renoir is maturity
is another way of talking about the
complexity or the richness of his films
but it's a I simply want to remind you
at the end that one way to think about
what Renoir is doing is is to recognize
that his his visual style is in some
sense an embodiment of the ambition not
to simplify right to be as fluid and as
attentive to the world as it's possible
to be and one can see that that one
could say that that visual that that
that commitment to that commitment to
the way the camera acts toward the world
is a version of a larger kind of
maturity or complexity that's revealed
in the content of his work as well take
the characters I've already mentioned
the key point here the way in which the
characters are both flawed full of
weaknesses but also attractive in
certain ways the way in which Rosenthal
is marred by his pride in his family's
wealth the way in which the gabon
character is marred by his anti-semitism
in his lack of education the way in
which the Dubois Jew character is
damaged or limited by the by his
reserved by his aristocratic reserve and
his impulse toward a kind of
condescending superiority which you can
see articulated in the very first moment
you see him at the very beginning of the
film where he's just disking about the
incompetence of his own troops so
there's a complexity of character that
reflects the maturity of the film's
vision of life and there's a complexity
in the story because think of it for a
minute this is a war story but it's a
war story without battles some people
have said it's the happiest war story
they ever saw one way of organizing the
film is to see it as a series of meals
in which in which characters sit down a
table and share convivial thoughts right
it's not only they're not a sufficient
way of thinking about them but it's a
partial way of thinking about it so so
although it's a film about war about the
consequences of war it doesn't show
shooting and in fact although it's a war
story it's about most deeply human
community and human solidarity and about
historical transition well one way to
crystallize all of this or to summarize
it is to remind you of the complexity of
the title grand illusion
what could the the title seems to me to
have at least four separate implications
or four separate ways of understanding
and the fact that it's it's a measure of
what I've called multiplicity or
complexity right how would what what
would the title mean what what is the
grand illusion to which the title refers
well one is surely this remember the
film was made on the eve of World War
two even though it is ostensibly said in
World War one and in fact it was
recognized as an anti-war film it was
banned in Germany and in Italy President
Roosevelt in the United States said
anyone who loves freedom should see this
film I think he was right the title one
of the things about that war that that
first world war some of you will know
was it was identified especially by the
American President Woodrow Wilson as the
war to end Wars so one deep grand but
horrible illusion is that this is the
war to end Wars that there won't be any
more Wars after this one a second
possible meaning of the title is this um
there's a one of the central events in
the film I haven't mentioned yet and
it's maybe the most memorable interlude
in the film is after Marechal and
Rosenthal make their escape from one of
the prison camps they're on the run they
can't be they but they're in Germany and
they're in the middle of winter and they
managed to find safety in the home of a
German woman who is uh whose husband is
away at the war perhaps dead and she she
is they're trying to manage a farm with
her young daughter Elsie and Elsa and
and Marichal and Rosenthal spend the
winter with them and and they get and
it's a it's an idol in the winter so
think about what and in fact it's very
moving and again the barriers of
language are present there at the very
end of the of their Idol in the woods we
have Mara she'll say to to the child I
think her name is
I called her Elsa I think it's Lottie he
says he looks at the girl he says he
tried in bad German he says Lottie has
blue eye he says blue eyes but he's very
proud of himself for having been able to
articulate to a German word but the fact
that he's done that is a mark of his
having you know reached out and the
implication more than
location is he becomes the woman's lover
the while there while they spend the
winter in this way and and the German
woman at a certain point when they first
take refuge in her place the doors a
German soldier searching for these guys
comes to the comes to the door comes to
the window and speaks to the widow and
the widow protects them right so so a
second grand illusion may very well be
look this is a very lovely story but how
believable is it Germans French soldiers
on the run from a prison camp find find
a a farmhouse in which a German Widow
takes them in and protects them from the
German soldiers that would be an it's a
nice story but is it a grand if it is an
illusion maybe it's a grand one a
wonderful one not just a large one but a
valuable one right so that's a second
way in which the the title resonates for
me the third grand illusion has to do
with the community of the prisoners the
Solidarity and community that's
dramatized in the film in the end the
doobly-do character sacrifices himself
for the good of the others something
that we might find surprising at first
given his distance from the other
characters and there is a sense all the
way through the film that the that that
a kind of community or solidarity has
been established amongst the men
especially amongst the Frenchmen and
especially that a kind of friendship
between between Rosenthal and Marisa has
been forged
well again maybe that's a grand illusion
the idea that you can transcend social
class that you can transcend the ethnic
prejudices into which you are born and
to which you've been with which you've
been brainwashed so that's another kind
of potential grand illusion and then
finally the fourth example I would give
the four the fourth
nuance that one could add to the title
the grand illusion of movies themselves
what are movies but grand illusions
right there are two-dimensional not
three-dimensional but what we watch them
we feel we've entered into a real world
the grand illusion of movies themselves
is part of what the title alludes to
well something of the complexity and
maturity of
rewards vision of experience sense of
human character and sense of history is
embodied then in the complexity of the
title of his movie
you